this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [ __ ] it's
wednesday march the 30th and from the
heart of jersey the joint is brought to
you by [ __ ] draftkings join the
action on the court during the biggest
college basketball tournament of the
year this [ __ ] saturday sunday with
draftking sportsbook you got villanova
going up against kansas and duke against
north carolina listen new customers i'm
going to give you a deal of a lifetime
you're going to bet 5 hours on any team
to win and i'm gonna get you 200 miles
and free bets to continue your little
[ __ ] party until baseball season
happens and i'll tell you what if
sportsbook isn't available in your state
yet no problem you can still join the
college hoops action with draftking
pools let me tell you something about
draftkings pools they're [ __ ]
tremendous everybody can play and you
play for free in the month of march for
a shot at winning over 250 000
in [ __ ] prizes do me a favor right
now let's make some money this weekend
download the draftking sports book app
today right now use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
but five dollars on any college hoop
team to win and get 200 and free bets if
they do it's that easy
if they win you win i win just use promo
code joey j-o-e-y for this week at
draftkingsportsbook download it today 29
21 and over restrictions apply and if
they do just play the pool for free for
a chance to win over 200 000 in cash
[ __ ] prizes
use code joey the joint is also brought
to you by cbd lion when it comes to cbd
that are [ __ ] best from the bath ball
to the cream to the hemp that they sell
and now
not only do they have gummies with
melatonin
do me a favor just go to cbd line right
now and take a look at the [ __ ] delta
nine gummies they're [ __ ] tremendous
my wife ate one the other and she goes
joy give me the whole [ __ ] container
they put you to sleep they let me tell
you from the delta nine high and the
thci is two different things but they're
both [ __ ] tremendous i'm gonna get
your deal on these delta nine gummies
when you press encode joey or church on
cbdlion.com
read the third party lab results
and [ __ ] [ __ ] it but you gotta get the
delta nine [ __ ]
uh gummies with the cbd they're [ __ ]
tremendous you wake up like you got
10 000 fingers rubbing you and a finger
up your ass you decompress and you're
ready to sling dick but it starts with
you by going to
cbdlion.com right now
pressing code joey
and get the [ __ ] party started from
there the joint is also brought to you
by zip recruiter listen it's a great
idea to keep learning skills
you know me i've been learning the
guitar i'm not that good i go to jiu
jitsu i'm not that good but i'm always
learning because it keeps you sharp like
zip recruiter the ai is always learning
if you're hiring the ai gets better and
faster at finding the right candidates
for all your roles and right now you can
try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates
up with your job
you then review the candidates and
invite your choices to apply for your
job it's that easy that's why zip
recruiter is rated number one
hiring site in the u.s based on g2
ratings and now you could try zip
recruiter for free with this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y that's
slash ziprecruiter.com j-o-e-y zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
yes it is it's wednesday
the 29th of [ __ ] march or whatever
the [ __ ] 30th i don't know who gives a
[ __ ] anymore the 30th it's a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive
i'm very happy that you guys enjoyed the
podcast we did with the [ __ ] three
amigos
it was really great seeing uh lee and
steve simone
when they left it was very emotional for
me like i had a long day like i was
[ __ ] tired
our tolerance is [ __ ] definitely not
the same
i mean uh i gave lee an abx 200
milligram
with the [ __ ] cbo in it that
[ __ ]
was [ __ ] up on friday night friday
night we didn't really do much
i met them uh late they had their
chinese food
they were [ __ ] excited
uh that [ __ ] steve simone
showed up with two pies tomato pies from
philadelphia i forgot the guy's name but
i'm talking about i never had a tomato
pie it's like pizza with just sauce on
it
holy [ __ ] that thing was good then they
woke up saturday i had errands to run
and [ __ ] they woke up saturday
and went to uh
crispy pizza up in old bridge on the
516. [ __ ] tremendous
and then they went to aiello's uh
sandwich place one of the best sandwich
places in the area
and [ __ ] you know steve simone being
the catholic of life on a saturday he
went to church and prayed and [ __ ]
hung out with filipino people only
[ __ ] steve simone could find the
church in [ __ ] jersey that quick i
mean he got hit friday night and he was
at church on [ __ ] saturday praying
they went to carvel then they got here
we [ __ ]
i mean guys we didn't even really smoke
that was the crazy thing lee
maybe took uh three hits off of blunt
one night and then the next day took a
couple blunts but i gotta tell you
something as i was telling mike
[Music]
when people say to me they're looking to
change in their lives you know like
you're looking for your life to change
you know and you keep trying really hard
like you you don't know where to start
you know i have a friend that's really
heavy and when i see him
i could tell that
it's wearing on him and he's embarrassed
about his size
but he doesn't know where to start and
sometimes in life when you're looking to
change like what do i have to do first
and it's it's a
it's a tough thing some people work on
changing and others just let the
evolution uh you know happen naturally
it was funny because i hadn't seen lee
listen guys i had not seen lee
or steve simone since august
17th i left on the 19th but steve left
before me uh and so did
uh lee left that monday i left on a
thursday
and it's crazy that we have not seen
each other and whatever that is
september october november december
january february march
19 months
and looking at steve simone
looking at lee
and looking at myself even
it's amazing how much we've changed
and we didn't change for the worse we
changed for the better like if you guys
thought i was doing great doing the
church i was i was having a great time
but now thinking back looking
we were not [ __ ] healthy at all i
mean that was uh you could tell that i'm
smoking again because you can hear the
wheezing in my [ __ ] lungs and whatnot
and i don't give a [ __ ] you know it's
not like i'm going crazy here or
anything but
it's really hard to believe how much a
person could change
some people look
to change with like uh time
you know it's we even my diet
like guys i don't i have all this great
food around me
and i can honestly tell you
that because i'm getting older and
whatever my diet is different
like my diet is completely different i
won't i don't think we think my my body
could process like a a quarter pounder
with cheese if i got to cheat at
mcdonald's i go to mcdonald's twice a
year because anybody could afford you
know when you work out and lift and take
care of yourself you also have to [ __ ]
on your body once the wall also recovers
naturally when you eat mcdonald's it
breaks you to [ __ ] down for a few days i
swear at least it does me some people
eat mcdonald's and they [ __ ] whistle
while they work hitler is a jerk moose
anyway some people eat mcdonald's and
they [ __ ] you know
i eat mcdonald's that stays with me for
[ __ ] two or three days and that's why
i don't eat mcdonald's but when i do go
to mcdonald's you know i used to be able
to eat like a [ __ ]
this and that and take two apple pies
i can't do that no more even if i want
even if i'm stoned to the gills if i
overeat like i was overeating in my
early i [ __ ] feel like [ __ ] i feel
like [ __ ] if i eat fried foods
for a few days in a row i feel like [ __ ]
and when you're a kid you [ __ ] eat
fried chicken 22
[ __ ] pieces you blow a little hot oil
fart and you move on with your [ __ ]
life you know what i'm saying but once
you get older you just but it was the
the change has been
it was very impressive
you know uh
steve is still doing this thing in
florida he just took la and brought it
to florida with them you know when you
do that listen you can do stand up
anywhere that's the beauty of what we
[ __ ] do
okay you could do
stand-up locally you could do stand-up
in your area or you could do stand-up on
a national [ __ ] level you know
everybody has a different
goal everybody has a different take when
you start a back you're gonna see a band
they're doing [ __ ] cover songs the
whole [ __ ] hour and a half and you're
like where the [ __ ] are you going
you have to sometimes where the [ __ ] are
you going well when you play a wedding
and all that [ __ ] you got to play devil
with the blue dress on and [ __ ] and bars
i don't want to hear that [ __ ]
i don't want to hear that [ __ ] i don't
mind going to your show but i want you
to have a little original content you
know what i'm saying like a little
original content one [ __ ] song
everybody throws a song at you for
[ __ ] going to see them right like
hold on this is a song we wrote you're
like oh jesus here we go
violins come out an arrow flies through
the [ __ ] air
but i like that [ __ ] but
when you start comedy you have to decide
what you're gonna do when i started
comedy i started locally and you grow a
little bit and then you have to make a
decision
i could do [ __ ] triple runs all my
[ __ ] life or i could try to duke it
out with those [ __ ] savages in l.a
some people go to l.a and they leave in
two months and that makes the decision
for them i know who i am now i'm never
going to be on tv i don't want to be on
tv and i just want to do stand-up from
town to town 50 [ __ ] weeks a year
you're still a stand-up maybe people
won't know who the [ __ ] you are
but you're still a [ __ ] standout and
that's all that matters that you make a
living
you know sometimes being in the national
spotlight is a little bit [ __ ]
overrated for some [ __ ] people and
some people
just don't [ __ ] like it you know what
i'm saying but
you have to decide
what you want to do you know like right
now when i came back here my original
plan was to team up with artie and take
over [ __ ] new jersey
that was my original plan when i was on
the [ __ ] plane coming back to jersey
here with my wife and felicia and the
cats and i was like you know what i'll
go back to jersey take a look around say
which way the wind blows
and then meonardi will take over this
[ __ ] state and also i got here and i
i didn't want to do it but
for me to be happy to do it again i
would have to just do it locally
i don't want to talk to [ __ ] agents
every goddamn day about offers and [ __ ]
and that's the decision i would make i
would just do jersey new york
boston maybe stretch out to dc and keep
it there maybe pa i'm real close to all
those gigs in pa too but i don't want to
[ __ ] do comedy but if i wanted to do
comedy full-time i could take that i
already been to the uh
through a [ __ ] uh ringer right now it
would be easy for me now you know i
don't even give a [ __ ] if i got on stage
who's going to be there hbo i'm not
looking to shoot an hbo special you know
and that's all the things you have to
decide as a stand-up comic or even as a
human being what do you want to do what
type of attorney are you i'm going to do
be this type of [ __ ] return you have
to narrow it down when you write your
goals
you know it's it's [ __ ] up sometimes
and i did it for years
to write i just want to be a good
comedian
and that's
as simple as can be i just wanted to be
a good comedian what's that i know the
basics
i could store retail i could improvise a
little bit i could do anything when i do
stand up i could do anything i could
improvise as good of a lot a lot of
people that you've seen on the road the
problem with me is i don't like
improvising because it could go
a thousand different [ __ ] directions
you guys if i was doing an open mic and
you guys paid five bucks to get in i
don't give a [ __ ] what happens but when
you guys pay 25 and get a babysitter and
dinner and the whole [ __ ] thing i got
to give you the best show possible and
if i start improvising i'll improvise
for three four
five minutes but i go back to the
[ __ ] set list
and work myself around that you know and
that's
what i always wanted to do perfection i
want to go on stage you're never going
to be perfect
but i know that when those people left
my show
they knew that i left 100 on the stage
i'm fat i'm my face is red it looks like
i'm gonna [ __ ] my head's gonna blow
listen that [ __ ] left it all on
stage you know what i'm saying that's
that's classic so when you're looking to
change your life
you have to be very
specific
and what goals you're picking and how
you word your goals that's
basically what i wanted to say about
steve and uh
i'm very proud of him
i'm very proud of lee um
i'm gonna start to see him a little more
we made a little thing that maybe we'd
see each other a little more from time
to time
next time maybe michael join us for
dinner if he can you know mike's got to
watch the kids and [ __ ] it's a tough
life having kids i'm brother
[ __ ] tough man i was supposed to do
something sad sunday your plans change
when you have kids
people just don't really understand like
even at jiu jitsu
i can't go to jiu jitsu at night
for many reasons i'm too [ __ ] old
and by six o'clock i'm already done i'm
pooped i can't see myself running around
or whatever
so i go to day classes
and i know what i want to do this class
i go to on tuesdays and thursdays over
at his school at uh
at uh
hollis let me tell you something they
got a thing called like blue
and they drill and [ __ ] pass the
guard drill past the guard then you go
back to [ __ ] drilling then you go
back to pass and the [ __ ] gun guys
i've been there a couple times and i'm
still not in [ __ ] whatever shape but
i'm gonna catch up and i don't even know
how we got on [ __ ] jiu jitsu it's a
dumb thing but what i'm trying to tell
you [ __ ] that if you are
looking to change
don't sweat it it takes time everything
takes time that's why i tell people all
the time
just
keep
showing
up even when it came to jiu jitsu i'm
sorry to bring this up again
i get i was talking to a kid in jujitsu
one day he's not
uh there anymore he's in mexico he's a
financial guy he's coming back in six
months
and we were talking about he was telling
me how he's not putting enough time
into jiu jitsu you know and i go why is
that
and he goes a little bit of fear a
little bit of you know
he had a couple different whatever i
can't think about it right now but i i
focused on the fear part you know i have
that fear too sometimes sometimes before
i go to jiu jitsu how many times maybe
twice a month i'm going to jiu jitsu and
i turn the [ __ ] car around
because i'm just scared that day and i
go why the [ __ ] and then i feel like
[ __ ] for not going
then you feel like shift are not going
and the key thing here is just keep
showing up
you're not looking to be the best guy in
that [ __ ] class you're just
looking to be consistent which is the
most important thing in [ __ ] life
you know podcasting for example people
always ask me joey what's the number one
rule or what advice would you give me
and i always tell them consistency
whether you got a crawl
to do it
you got to do it on the same i would
love to just have a scattered schedule
like joe rogan he puts a podcast up
whenever the [ __ ] he wants i don't have
it that good
i have to stick to a schedule so you
guys know when to expect it and i know
when to give it to you it works a lot
you know let me you know
mike's got kids i got a [ __ ] kid you
know you're going to softball season i'm
like you know what
i think i'm just going to start doing
the podcast on mondays and wednesdays
and putting that on tuesdays and
thursdays i know i can't do that because
that would [ __ ] up a thousand people's
rotation why because i was consistent
with those two days
for the last [ __ ] 10 years for the
last 10 years we've been popping up on
your [ __ ] youtube every monday and
goddamn wednesday
consistency is so much in life just
sticking to the plan and guess what it's
[ __ ] boring
consistency
is [ __ ] boring
but that's what's gonna get you over the
[ __ ] hump is showing up showing up
showing up showing up even me saying it
is [ __ ] boring showing up showing up
showing up i can't [ __ ] show up every
day
but you can
but you can even if you're not there
physically
you could show up there mentally just
because i'm not on stage doesn't mean i
can't write right
just because you're not playing the
guitar
doesn't mean you can't [ __ ] uh
write songs if your hands broken you can
still write [ __ ] songs with one hand
you know whatever just the musical
chords i'm talking about putting them in
your [ __ ] head you know there's so
many different options
you know and today i'm sorry i was going
to have a guest today
and uh we
are timing you know this [ __ ] zoom
[ __ ]
sucks for me sometimes especially when i
got guys from california
because they think i say two o'clock and
it's two o'clock cali time it's really
11 o'clock
and this morning i was gonna have a
podcast with a musician a dear friend of
mine new to the podcast and we were
going to discuss you know the
what happened this last weekend you know
and you're like what what the [ __ ]
happened this last weekend because it's
something that you
i want you guys to grasp because it's
it's something that comes with life we
lost a [ __ ] great musician
this weekend
you guys know what's cool a thumb i come
from when it comes to music i like all
the guys like the older sounds i've
always loved the foo fighters
you know i think that every once in a
while they they get on my nerves because
they do everything they're always there
they're always [ __ ] there every
grammy they're there every mtv thing
they're there every like they were about
to do the grammys again in a couple of
weeks and i was like [ __ ] again with
the goddamn [ __ ] foo fighters
you know and that i'd love dave groh
he's uh
he's the uh
you know constant professional i mean
this guy
he's everything i love about him you
know no ego
uh
no ego no
no dick
he just um
you know
i remember hearing this and i remember
now talking to mike about it
you know his first album he played every
[ __ ] instrument that's prince type
[ __ ] that's that's legendary type [ __ ]
but then again if you know about prince
or you know about dave grohl they were
both in the same position they were
child prodigies
dave grow was a child prodigy uh what's
his name was forced to put him in the
band
because of the record labels suggested
the drummer dave grow he was just a
[ __ ] kid
when david grow joined the foo fighters
he was just a [ __ ] kid
nirvana i'm sorry nirvana [ __ ] i get
confused this reef is killing me
yeah he was a pumper he's a [ __ ]
young kid but the record label thought
he was a [ __ ] uh you know like this
[ __ ] out of this world thing so they
they talk to kurt i guess and they put
him in there him and prince are the same
they don't give a [ __ ] they ain't
waiting for you
they ain't waiting for you they're not
like me that i gotta wait for mike that
they ain't waiting for you you don't
wanna play the [ __ ] drums i'll play
the drums i play the flute i'll learn to
play the saxophone just to play this
[ __ ] song that's why i love prince
and that's why i love dave grow because
they're the constant musicians if
somebody had an ego
they wouldn't let somebody else play the
[ __ ] drums
if they thought that they were the best
[ __ ] drummer i like dave grow because
he's a team [ __ ] player he does
whatever is needed
to make the music go on you need me to
[ __ ] kick in the ass while you're
[ __ ] singing i'll do it you need me
to play the [ __ ] cowbell i'll do it i
think this needs a helicopter in it i'll
do it and that's like with with stand-up
comedy you can't be jealous of the other
guy
you got to applaud that other guy
because by you applauding that guy that
young guy you're making yourself
stronger as a comic or a musician
if i was jimmy page i could just tell
people to go [ __ ] himself
right if you
if i was [ __ ] joe perry from
aerosmith you come to me with some
[ __ ] story about a guitar i tend to
go jump out a [ __ ] window i've done a
thousand shows in arenas i [ __ ] put
together 10 12 of the best albums you've
ever heard and you want to come tell me
a story get the [ __ ] out of my face
somebody come to if i'm [ __ ] joe
perry somebody comes to me oh there's a
new kid randy rhodes go [ __ ] yourself
you know what i'm saying i was doing
heroin when randy rhodes was born what
is randy going to say to me and then you
look at randingo he's a [ __ ] tank
but yeah he was a tank god rest his soul
and that's what this death reminds me of
this taylor hawkins death you know it
was weird that ozzy osbourne's uh david
tom rhodes's tom wrote
randy rhodes anniversary of death
was a week ago
and i know a lot of you guys were not
around for this in 1982.
it was crushing
i know you guys think i'm a [ __ ] geek
when it comes to music and i am
i am i take it personally i cry i get
pissed i throw [ __ ] like i told you you
call me a fats pick and i walk away from
you tell me led zeppelin sucks were
wrestling we're wrestling you know i'm
saying like we're gonna argue first and
then tempers are gonna flare we're gonna
throw punches you tell me my mother's a
[ __ ] you know she's dead what do i give
a [ __ ]
she's a [ __ ] in heaven but
you know if you want to argue with me
argue music i'll argue with you in the
temp is a flare and the whole [ __ ]
thing you know but
i
remember like
you know you got to set it up i mean
listen the foo fighters didn't mean to
me what they meant to mike mike's a real
foo fighter [ __ ] guy he lives and
dies he knows the sun here one by one he
knows the songs backwards and front
words i know more about like led
zeppelin i'm a fan of [ __ ] uh
foo fighters but they didn't live or die
for me but let me tell you a little
story
my mother had died
i was lost and the only thing that was
keeping me alive was listen until we
sold our soul for rock and roll as dumb
as it sounds people as dumb as that
sounds there's sometimes
that there's just a couple things that
are keeping you alive you know and i
know it you know you guys have rough
days you're like [ __ ] i'm gonna go
jump off a bridge
and while you're walking there you go i
can't i love my tricycle you know what
i'm saying like i love my [ __ ]
bicycle whatever there's always
something it's the simplest [ __ ]
thing
for me it's all i had at
17 was [ __ ]
ozzie and judas priest and ac dc and i
probably lived vicariously to them
because i didn't want to live my life
because it sucked i was hurting from
[ __ ] hated i was a walking band-aid
okay
and i still remember man [ __ ] taking
ahead of acid on my birthday the day ac
the day uh bon scott died
1980
and we did a bunch of crazy [ __ ] and on
the walk home we stopped at a magazine
store
and i'll never forget picking up cream
the magazine cream and seeing that
uh ozzie was putting a band together
blah blah blah blah they didn't give you
names or nothing like that at the time
they just told you he's putting a band
together so i was excited that gave me
some time to talk [ __ ] i thought the
band would be called uh blizzard of oz
which it was
which made me you know i was a cocaine
guy anybody blizzard snowstorm any of
that [ __ ] got my [ __ ] dick card so
i just knew i even got a shirt made the
blizzard of oz
you know my own little blizzard with a
[ __ ] line of coke on it i was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] i get it
then finally came the chance when the
tickets went on sale for ozzy at the
palladium and i got rudy
and you got randy rhodes i didn't look
at that and now i ended up being friends
with rudy sargo
40 [ __ ] years later
so i'm sitting there we [ __ ] get the
tickets we go to the concert tremendous
at the palladium think of seeing ozzie
oz one of the 1500 seat maybe 1800 seats
it's like watching somebody at town hall
in new york city and [ __ ] phenomenal
like when i went to see guns n roses or
bill burr at the palladium you can't ask
for anything more that's when you really
want to see a [ __ ] band let it all
out
i went i had a great time came home i
was hook line and sinker randy rhodes
[ __ ] the guitar solo on uh
goodbye to no whatever goodbye to
romance just so many [ __ ] things i
was hooked
and all of a [ __ ] sudden
my friends are going to pick me up it's
march we're going to go out we're going
to get high we're going to do this
and as i got in fernie basta sudo's car
he goes did you just hear it it came on
the radio
randy rhodes died i was blown away
you know at that time my life anybody
could have died and i didn't expect it
but randy rose
one album he had the other one in the
can i think when he died the
diary of a madman i'm not sure i don't
want to [ __ ] make the wrong statement
here but
it threw me for a [ __ ] loop as a 17
year old kid
i was hurting for a few days as
dumb
as that [ __ ] sounds i was like what
the [ __ ] can this guy die
this is just my [ __ ] luck you know
and then time moved on and you know
you do more coke
you know you do more drinking you do
more quaaludes the pain goes away
but
you know this weekend like i said i'm
not even a [ __ ] big uh whatever fan
but i'm a fan of life
i'm a fan of human beings i'm a fan of
people but
when i woke up and i looked at instagram
whatever the [ __ ] and i saw people
posting pictures of him i think that i
go this is a [ __ ] mistake i just
heard last night that they're doing the
[ __ ] grammys
how can this kid be [ __ ] dead
and uh
it's
it's really [ __ ] mind-boggling guys
you know like when somebody dies like
that
i didn't know i loved to tell you i knew
him all the people put pictures up
jumping up and down with him i didn't
know him i didn't need to know him to
feel
i didn't need to know him to feel you
know and i wish
i always have a little empathy when i
see somebody died a mom died a dad died
a kid died you know i always have
a little bit of empathy there's some you
know
11 people got shot at a baseball game
[ __ ] it why would you go to that game it
sucked anyway you know like just dumb
[ __ ] you know like just
dumb [ __ ] but
every once in a while somebody dies and
i gotta [ __ ] tell you man it throws
me for a loop
i gotta think about the situation and i
gotta process it as much as
if i knew the human being
isn't that [ __ ] weird like i know
you know brody i knew brody i knew
[ __ ] ralphie i knew these guys
i never knew taylor hawkins that's his
name right taylor hawkins because i'm
bad with names i don't want to insult
him when the guy's dead if he was alive
we wouldn't be having this conversation
but i was talking to taylor hawkins i
would say anything
any other stupid [ __ ] you know but it's
just weird how
death
[ __ ] with you look at my sister
i haven't seen my sister since i was
[ __ ] three i'm not gonna lie to you
guys
for 20 something years we didn't have
contact and then we started talking
again maybe the last 10 [ __ ] years 12
years you know
and we spoke maybe once a month i
offered to bring her up she refused i
got a little hot under the collar but i
lived
the [ __ ] main thing is that
i didn't know her let's be honest how
much would i [ __ ] know
i knew it from conversations or whatever
i got a text one day on a podcast that
she did
i got a text a week before that she was
dying
but it's cuba they could save you
because they just don't give you a pill
and send you home but they also gave her
a [ __ ] expiration date they said she
should make it another week but they'll
try to save it when i got the [ __ ]
text come on guys who the [ __ ] are you
kidding you know
i haven't seen her i haven't seen her in
uh since 1966.
i gotta be honest you guys it's [ __ ]
weight on me the last two weeks
i think tomorrow i'm gonna go up and uh
put some flowers on my mother's grave
i've been a little hesitant it's been
[ __ ] cold in jersey snow and raining
uh so i gotta do a little spring
cleaning and maybe i'll go up there and
uh bring a sandwich
bring some flowers bring the [ __ ]
thing and
spend an hour or two on the grave
manicuring it [ __ ] killing some weeds
pull out bring some gloves
and put some flowers and just sit with
them maybe eat a [ __ ] sandwich
smoke a joint blow the smoke into the
[ __ ] uh
tombstone and uh
go from there you know but
i don't know her
and i got to be honest here the last
couple weeks it has it's been a little
difficult for me
i made my calls i wrote a letter to her
i wrote a letter to my mother
you know to
forgive me for my behavior towards my
sister even though i didn't do anything
wrong you know i when i tell you guys
something uh on a podcast i also do it i
i love writing letters
so i wrote a letter i wrote a letter to
my mother put the address on in
northberg and everything just didn't put
a return address and put in the mail man
i felt
a lot [ __ ] better guys you know you
just
you just feel better sometimes that's
what it's all about is uh a lot of
people call it closure
but i just like to [ __ ] uh lock it
down
and another [ __ ] tremendous news that
everybody's been bugging me about
you guys i didn't i listen guys i don't
watch the oscars i got the [ __ ] out of
there i don't watch the oscars
and i don't want to watch the [ __ ]
oscars i know exactly what they are
you know i'm happy
i like the movie king richard you know i
enjoyed it i was
excited for it i wanted
to see the story
yeah they put facts and [ __ ] i've
always been a [ __ ] movie buff
and i've always had the utmost respect
for uh
movies i i [ __ ] love them i i adore
movies guys i got into this business
because of [ __ ] movies because i
loved everything to do with them i liked
talking about them i like everything
i did not watch the academy awards on
sunday night i woke up monday morning
to all this [ __ ] the calls from
newspapers i had messages from
newspapers that wanted to think what
wanted to know what i thought and stuff
like that
can you imagine how much
yeah i'm a fat [ __ ] felon you know
what
i had like two calls from newspapers for
me to call back and
give uh whatever the [ __ ] i thought i
got to be honest with you guys i didn't
think anything
i didn't think anything i saw jimmy this
morning at the gym
jimmy thinks it's a fix that it was
staged to smack
because he actually bent over and waited
to get smacked
it's kind of weird and
and will laugh and then will turn around
when he was walking back to the thing he
was smiling
i didn't see the whole thing guys first
off guys you know what let's start with
this
everybody in that room is [ __ ]
disgusting in their own little ways i
know that you guys uh
pray to them and care about what the
[ __ ] they got to say and stuff if there
was 200 people in that room if there was
200 actors there five of them have the
ability to be real
for more than a [ __ ] hour
okay everything is great tremendous you
were great oh my god you know
amazing i love when they use that
amazing
and they get all serious about it and
whatnot but
i i don't know what the [ __ ] to expect i
don't know what the [ __ ] you guys want
me to say to you
so let's break it the [ __ ] down the way
i saw it you know he said a joke
they giggled
his wife gave him a look
he went up there smack chris rock
chris rock didn't do a [ __ ] thing
not even throw karate block i don't even
know if chris rock ever went to [ __ ]
martial arts
you know they got the [ __ ] high block
you got the side block and you got the
[ __ ] low block you know then put up a
block
and uh
he walked back to the thing no security
was there
you know a lot of people mad about
where was the [ __ ] security where was
the smack in the face
guys i i don't know
you're gonna stump me with this one
yeah chris rock looked at the side i
thought they were gonna pull it down i
didn't guys i don't know what to say i
love chris rock
you know you guys know i made a movie
with him i've done a couple [ __ ]
shows with him
he's always been very good to me but
again i don't know what happened and i
don't want to say something on the
negative side and chris rock finds out
but
i heard that chris rock has a big tour
starting friday and that he sold more
tickets
yesterday
than he did when he started the tour and
released the tickets for [ __ ] sale
you know
i don't like
getting [ __ ] hit
i don't like getting hit
and one of the reasons during the
pandemic that i did not want to go out
for comedy is i felt that people
were going to be a little wild let's
flip it back here if you guys
listen to one of the ralphie made
churches
i don't know which one he said yeah i
don't know which number it is i don't
know how many episodes rafi was on
but uh if you look at ralphie's one of
the episodes he did
we had a conversation about
someday we feel a comic is gonna get
shot on stage
like someday
a comic is gonna get [ __ ] shot on
stage
and it stayed with me for a couple
minutes i never really thought about it
you know comedy clubs don't have metal
detectors they don't have anything you
know you've heard of
hecklers and comics
getting into arguments with hecklers and
the cops come and they get thrown out i
never like when the cops come i always
think that there's a
a better solution to it
i didn't like it for the simple reason i
got a lot of friends with stand-up
comics that my brothers some of them my
sisters
and by people seeing somebody walk up to
the stage again
it's a once-in-a-lifetime thing of
happening
but i would hate to see it happen in
real life with one of my comic friends
whether it be bert
tom
joe
it could be anybody you know it could be
anybody
i worry about that a lot i worry about
my comic bodies especially what was
going on in the world right now you know
a lot of people are not mentally healthy
a lot of people want to laugh but they
go to a show and somebody says something
wrong and uh
they go to the manager or they'll get a
fence
we're living in different times now guys
i mean how we how lee and i and steve
and mike and how we've changed
the world has changed in [ __ ] 19
months
and
people are just not healthy a lot of
people lost their businesses a lot of
people lost a lot of money a lot of
people lost wages a lot of people lost
loved ones and uh
it's a rough time right now i think that
i know that you guys think that we're
past it all and everybody's jumping up
and down no we're not we still got a lot
coming on this [ __ ] thing before
we're back to 100 percent um
i don't know what the answer is going to
be to make people happier or whatnot
or to make people realize that our
behavior is wrong you know
i'm seeing both sides of the spectrum on
this will smith stuff
you see somebody like
tiffany haddish that says it was a
beautiful thing
that it was beautiful to see a man stick
up for his woman
that's one look
that's one way to look at it um
another way to look at is uh people
saying that it was he was too sensitive
people can't take a joke
so they won't
want to go up there and smack somebody
some people say that violence is never
the answer
we're touching him or smacking him
i respect chris rock for not pressing
charges
you know i really do respect
chris rock for not pressing charges and
filing police report
um he
stayed to his true
comedian roots you know
no police were street guys i mean
i i don't know if chris is a heavy
you know i don't know if chris would
turn around
and try to smack him in the face or
whatever
but i've never seen chris like that
and uh
i don't know you know me i would
at least try to throw a punch
or a kick
but that wasn't me and i wasn't there
you know would i get intimidated because
it was will smith
if i threw a punch back at him will i
ever work again these are all the things
that got to be going through your
[ __ ] mind
the whole world's watching it's it's
this was a tough [ __ ] night for
everybody and nobody can explain it and
doug i wish i had a [ __ ] explanation
for you guys but i don't i don't i just
think that
i don't think it's uh
i don't think it was cool all around if
chris
this is a publicity stunt
to sell tickets
i don't think it was cool if this was uh
my man will smith's way of [ __ ] uh
listen guys the will smith
jada pinker relationship is very [ __ ]
complicated
i'm not i don't work for tmz
i don't work for [ __ ] people i i
don't know any about this [ __ ]
i'm just telling you what i've heard
from good friends of mine that
know what's going on in that house or
they have relationship with them i i
just
15 years ago somebody pulled me aside
and
he was an african-american guy and he we
were talking about african-american
comic and we were talking about all the
you know
secrets in the black community we're
talking about you know eddie murphy
being gay and how everybody [ __ ] hit
it you know how everybody hid
and i love her i hope nobody takes this
out of content how queen latifah was a
lesbian and she had all these little
[ __ ] girlfriends uh jada pinkett
being one of them again
i didn't say it i'm just telling you
what i [ __ ] heard
and uh it's hollywood guys
it's hollywood listen the mind of the
actor is
to be a little better than you
you know the reason why
they get 20 million dollars a movie and
whatever you guys in your mind go oh my
god he's better than me but he's not
he's not he picked an occupation
that he's good at and he built it up to
make 20 million dollars but you on the
other hand are like oh i'm not good
enough i will never be good enough to do
that and trust me i was the same person
i would sit there for years and go i'll
never be good enough to move to la i'm
never going to be good enough to do this
or that it's [ __ ] you're good enough
put that [ __ ] effort in you know
but for some reason people in them have
a set that all these people you see on
tv
all these multi-millionaires
they're better than you they're [ __ ]
not
not by they got no [ __ ] class they
got money
they got money
and you know what sometimes money does
by class
will i up my status if i put a georgio
cabana suit on and a tuxedo with a bow
tie no i'm still a [ __ ] pig i'm still
a guy that [ __ ] put the guy in the
trunk i'm still a guy that robbed a
[ __ ] donation thing from a carvel one
time for blind kids you know even though
they weren't probably gonna get the
money they got a penny out of that
[ __ ] jar you know i still did it so
i know these things these people in
their mind they think they're [ __ ]
better than you guys
and unless you're around it you'll never
know how that feels
you'll never know how that feels for
somebody to be breathing the same
[ __ ] air you're breathing and to walk
around like they're a [ __ ] saint you
know what
and i know
guys my first five or six years in la i
played that [ __ ]
and once i got off that [ __ ] cocaine
and i got back to joey diaz new jersey
joey diaz i realized that every one of
these [ __ ]
puts their pants on one leg at a time
all of them they think they're just
[ __ ] better than you you them all
years put your pants on one leg at a
time so get that thought out of your
[ __ ] mind god didn't give extra
talents to him or dave chappelle or
[ __ ] uh kyrie irving or [ __ ] jimmy
page no
these people put in the [ __ ] time
and in in
contrast to that somewhere along the
line they forget who the [ __ ] they are
i again i'm very tight with tiffany
haddish i love it at that and i'll tell
her this when i talked to her next
i saw what she said to the [ __ ]
reporter you know how she went off the
reporter and she's like this is the look
of money this is the look of all this
[ __ ]
but that's
what happens to you guys you're around
that [ __ ]
when i go on a movie set if i have
people bringing me water and asking me
well you know how do you feel mr diaz
after a while some people actually
believe that they're better me i always
had a better head than i didn't believe
that [ __ ] why are you getting me water i
could walk over to get my wall it's like
the the concept of an assistant in l.a
who else has a [ __ ] assistant that
you know in in jersey pennsylvania
connecticut texas who's got a [ __ ]
assistant but in l.a they need an
assistant because you have no idea how
busy i am i'm so stressed it's a
complete
[ __ ] scene
so
you know it's it's funny how
in 1994 i was doing comedy and
guys i was not the best joe diaz at at
all at that time at that point in my
life i was not a good [ __ ] joe diaz i
was going through a divorce i was
stealing to stay alive i was
you know it was just uh
it was a weird [ __ ] time and this is
why i tell people all the time in your
life
bro be careful about that because you
never know what that other person is
going through at the time
maybe he woke up this morning and he got
fired
then after that he went home and his dog
got hit by a car then he found out his
wife sucked the midget's dick then he
found out that he didn't get the [ __ ]
mortgage payment and you have no idea
what's going on with a human being
i went to do comedy one night because i
felt that's what i needed to do that's
what i am i'm a comic i got to get out
when i was in 94 and i was starting i
was in the business for four years if i
wasn't doing three sets a night i wasn't
[ __ ] working what are you talking
about being a comic
you got to get out there [ __ ] tv [ __ ]
your girlfriend [ __ ] everybody go out
there do comedy snort coke and get your
dick sucked
rinse repeat do it again the next
[ __ ] day that's it that's what you do
in your comic so one wednesday night i
went to do my [ __ ] uh you know my
my ritual and i gotta be honest with you
i don't know if you guys know this story
but on
wednesdays and sundays i would have uh
you know visitation with my daughter and
when it left when they would pick her up
like go to meet and they'd give me
[ __ ] attitude and i couldn't knock
them the [ __ ] out i would be really
upset i was not i think i was more in
pain than when my mother died than when
i wasn't seeing my daughter to make a
long [ __ ] story short i i
one wednesday they picked her up and i
sat in my car for 20 minutes crying and
i would roll a joint leave it in my
ashtray and i smoked the [ __ ] joint
and i said you know stop being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] coco get your [ __ ] pants on and
go do comedy don't worry about the kid
and what's going on in your world and
that's what i went and did on the way
home
i went to denver or some [ __ ] on the way
i stopped at my usual haunt on wednesday
nights
which was club 52 club 58 whatever the
[ __ ]
and i get there some kids are flipping
bottle caps you know i noticed this
while i'm eating
i'm an open mica i got maybe 24 minutes
of material and i go up there two before
the headliner and when i went up there i
wasn't in the mood
i just told the guys i go listen guys
don't flick any [ __ ] bottle caps the
first bottle cap i'm gonna go [ __ ]
off and sure enough
this little dick flicks a [ __ ] thing
at me and then
i i knew if i went into the audience i
would get beat up
so
i called him a bunch of names and then
he ran to me and i hit him in the head
with the [ __ ] microphone
you know i don't want anybody in my area
i don't know how i would
i don't know how i would do today if
somebody walked up to the mic especially
with lawsuits and
witnesses and [ __ ] cameras and [ __ ]
but me and my world
you walk up to me when i'm on [ __ ]
stage charge me or something like that i
i don't know
i think i'm gonna have to throw a
[ __ ] this fat [ __ ] leg up and kick
you in the [ __ ] head
and then what's gonna happen
you know what's gonna [ __ ] happen
that's what i would have done
but i'm a street piece of [ __ ] so i
respect chris rock for not going back at
will
or whatever the [ __ ] happened you know
guys it's better we don't even talk
about these type of subjects because at
the end of the week who gives a [ __ ]
how does will smith smack and chris rock
or chris rock
smack and will smith affect your [ __ ]
life you know i do know one thing and
this is what i don't feel good about
i do know that if mel gibson would have
smacked chris rock that night
it would have been a different [ __ ]
story
mel gibson would have been in jail right
now
think about what i'm telling you this
again i'm not speaking racism i'm not
speaking anything like that i'm just
speaking
what if somebody else would have done
this what if somebody white would have
done this
to a black dude on a [ __ ] i mean there
would have been a war if mel gives
someone to smack chris rock i mean
denzel would have jumped on him and
the [ __ ] dude from mateo's movies the
big black dude that's a big [ __ ]
whether he's gay or not that's a big
[ __ ] so
yeah what's his name
tala perry i like his work i like
everything about him but
uh
so i want you to think of that
how would that have been different
you know
should the academy strip will smith list
was the academy in on the chris rock
[ __ ] thing
you know what man we all have an opinion
and then we move the [ __ ] on because
like i said
it's got nothing
to do with your life or nothing to do
how you handle yourself and with that
said i'm sorry about the guest today
it happens what are you gonna [ __ ] do
welcome to the life for zoom after we
did the podcast last week with the
guests in here i i think it looks like
we could do some [ __ ] guests in the
future and if there's somebody i really
like and i
wanted to come to the house
i'll [ __ ] have me that's the big
thing about having a podcast at your
house
that people got to come to your house
people that don't know you know when you
have these names they bring their
assistant
you know what i'm saying and
that's the problem i don't want those
[ __ ] assistants in my house i don't
want no [ __ ] entourages in my house i
don't want none of the [ __ ] in my
house
and that's it and that's that i'm
excited about this weekend you got
villanova against [ __ ] uh
kansas
i don't know what the line is yet kansas
got a great defense and you got north
carolina against duke and that's why
you're gonna go to [ __ ] draftkings
this is a great weekend to go to
draftkings i think that's a final four
with the [ __ ] championship being uh
the following monday i'm looking forward
to that i'm looking forward to my
daughter's softball games this week that
comes back into uh into the [ __ ]
action
and that's the end of [ __ ] march guys
we did it we blew
past this [ __ ] [ __ ] month all i
remember about march is saint patty's
day and today and it's the [ __ ] 30th
so it's all over so friday same is uh
april fool's day
so maybe uh they'll come out and tell us
that that was an april fool's prank what
chris rock and his [ __ ]
compadre did but without that and
further ado
i love you [ __ ] with all my
heart uh
we're gonna keep making this podcast
better mike is a [ __ ] genius with the
lights and this and that and we'll
figure it out in time this will be the
[ __ ] savage [ __ ] podcast
and uh you guys will be happy i love you
[ __ ] with all my heart have a
great week and now for a word for my
[ __ ] sponsors jack
all right you bad [ __ ] thank
you for supporting the joint for
supporting me for helping me and micah
and uh always having us on the [ __ ]
playlist
listen before we go a quick [ __ ] note
this weekend is the ncaa [ __ ]
championship college basketball and i'll
tell you what you got to join in on the
action with draftking sportsbook this
weekend is the week people wait all year
for this you got duke versus north
carolina and you got kansas versus
villanova new customers i'm gonna hook
you up you're gonna bet finals on any
team to win and you're doing alls and
free bets if they do it's that easy if
you win i win everybody [ __ ] wins now
if sport book isn't available in your
state listen you can still join the
[ __ ] excitement with draftkings pools
everyone can play free pools
the whole month of march that's three
more [ __ ] days two more days today
and tomorrow for a shot at a shared over
250 thousand dollars in prizes but it
starts with you download the draftkings
sportsbook app today use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
but fidel on any college hoops team and
if to win you get 250 and free bets if
they do that's it it's that easy and if
you win like i said we win you win with
promo code joey this week at draftkings
sportsbook again if you don't have
gambling in your state yet listen you'd
be an idiot if you didn't go on
draftkings pools with a chance to win
250 000
remember you got to be 21 and over
restrictions apply
see show notes for details
draftkings the best the joint is also
brought to you by cbd lion when it comes
to cbd they're my [ __ ] partner i love
them i've been working with them for
years the kinesiology tape the [ __ ]
cream the gummies with melatonin and now
like i said in the beginning delta nine
and they're stronger than [ __ ] but it
starts with you go to cbdlion.com
press and code joey and get 20 off 20
off delivered right to your house that's
a [ __ ] steal
draft uh
cbdline.com
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by zip recruiter listen it's always
a great idea to keep [ __ ] learning
you got to learn something every day i
read i go to jiu jitsu i learn new moves
i play the guitar i learn new moves
you're always learning and it keeps you
sharp like zip recruiter listen if
you're hiring zip recruiter will find
you the right candidate for all your
positions and right now you could try a
zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey j-o-e-y let me tell you how it
works zip recruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates
up with your job you then review the
candidates and invite your choices to
apply for your job it's not easy that's
why ziprecruiter is the number one rated
hiring site in the us based on g2
ratings listen you're looking for help
get the best help available to you
download zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire listen
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank cbd lion i want to thank
ziprecruiter stamps.com
and better help and freeze pipe and
everybody else in our [ __ ] hemisphere
for always having our back and you guys
for always having my back i love you
stay black have a great week and we'll
be back monday morning tip top magoo do
me a favor [ __ ]
don't forget to download this sports
book app
the draftking sportsbook app make a
little money this week with [ __ ]
north carolina and kansas i love you
stay black
i'll see you monday morning tip top
[ __ ] magoo
[Music]
you